Welcome back, our next guest is a very good friend of mine
and I love it when she comes to visit.
This is like bring your friend to work today.
I love her.
You know her as the Co-Anchor
of one of the best and most important shows on television,
"The Today Show."
(audience cheer and clap)
And luckily, she is here right now with us today.
Please welcome Savannah Guthrie.
(audience cheer and clap)
(upbeat music)
Hi, hi everybody.
Look, we're both in our, we didn't even plan this.
We did not.
I know, we literally were like,
"Oh my God, we both wore skirts."
I actually did think of you though.
I was like, "This is a good Drew skirt."
This is actually a dress and I just put this thing over it.
Really?
Yes, so that's that, yeah.
Okay, we just spent your 50th birthday party together.
Yes we did.
It was so fun.
(audience cheer and clap)
You were so sweet to come.
It's the first and only party I've been to.
Well, it was kind of crazy.
We decided to do it.
I mean, I'm turning 50.
I felt like I'm not gonna hide out
or be all mopey about it.
I'm actually super happy.
I love middle age.
Let's hear it for middle age.
(audience cheer and clap)
And so we had a party.
It was a New Year's Eve party,
and you were so sweet to come.
And we had fun, and we danced
and it was just a really fun thing to do.
I thought, "You know what, this is a reason to get together
"and now we finally have something to do."
It was so fun.
Thank you for having me.
It was the most fun.
I needed that in my life.
It was such a gift to everybody to do something safe,
and normal, and communal and celebratory.
And I think it's what actually sent me into 2022
in the best mood ever.
I have been feeling so good this year.
Well, you know what,
(audience clap)
I don't like New Year's Eve, but I love a new year.
Don't you?
I mean, I just like to start something new, start fresh.
It's just full of possible.
Did you not like New Year's Eve ever though,
for the idea of kissing a stranger, mistletoe
or stranger new year's kiss?
Can I tell you something?
What?
I didn't need New Year's Eve to kiss strangers
when I was young.
(Drew screams)
I did not need an occasion to make out.
I don't wanna give out the wrong impression.
Were you a make out bandit?
I was a make out bandit.
Me too!
It was like seventh grade,
don't even try to like put your hand up my shirt.
I was good girl, but I did like to make out.
Fist base, I used to walk into places
and just be like, "You, right now."
I was so daring.
I know, me too.
I kind of miss those days.
Me too!
Well, you can.
You're drop dead gorgeous and single.
You can make out all the time.
I'll be your wing woman.
I need you to be my wing woman.
But you know what our problem is?
We like to meet literally at 3:30 or 4:00 PM
in the afternoon.
We have a date this weekend and I'm like,
"Are you sure you wanna wait 'til four?
"I can do earlier."
I go, "Four."
She goes, "Sure, and if you wanna come earlier,
"we can do it earlier."
Okay listen, I wore all my earrings in honor of you today.
I swear, I was just admiring all this.
Look at the bling.
So I did it.
I'm gonna snatch that right off of you.
You can have it all.
It's beautiful.
Maria Tash.
I love Maria Tash!
I have many Maria Tash.
Okay, how many do you have?
I can't believe it, I have four in each ones.
None of them are the same.
They're all different.
Our friend, Carson Daly is like,
"Savannah, you and my wife are trying to turn back the hands
"of time with this ear piercing thing."
I do, it's given me adornment.
It feels a little sexy.
It feels more in touch with who I used to be.
My 16 year old self was very spiritual.
She was very cool.
And she's not to be dismissed now
because we're working moms.
No, and I like all your rings to.
See, we're definitely on the same page.
Yeah, what is it?
Why are we doing this?
What's happening to us?
I'm like, "This is my rebellion."
It's like I just wanna a secret punk rocker,
or goth, or something.
What I don't have and you do, and I'm admiring is a tattoo.
Would you ever get a tattoo?
I would, and I kind of want to right now.
My mother's just rolling her eyes, but-
One, two, three, go, you're at a tattoo parlor
and this is it, you're getting one.
What is it?
Okay, I would like something.
I'm copying someone actually that I work with.
She had her mom's handwriting lightly done like yours is.
And her mom wrote, "Love you more."
'Cause that's what they say to each other.
So I would actually like something cool like that
with my mom.
My mom turns 80 today by the way.
Oh my God, happy birthday!
(audience cheer and clap)
I feel like we need to leave the studio
and go get this tattoo in honor of her 80th birthday.
I would get a tattoo with you anytime.
Do you wanna get another one?
Yeah, I wanna get one right here.
Okay, so why don't we go?
And I know exactly what I want.
What are you gonna say?
I wanna put 2:22 in the digital clock font
because my birthday is February 22nd,
and this year it's going to be 2, 22, 22.
Oh, I love that.
So I'm doing it this year.
Okay, so let's go
Let's go, done!
(audience cheer and clap)
We're doing it.
(upbeat music)